this program is brought to you by Emory
University
so the study is a rehabilitation study
that involves looking at people who have
had a stroke or a hemorrhage in the
brain and it is the goal is to improve
upper limb movement in people who had a
stroke so this treatment that we're
using our this intervention that we're
testing as part of this research study
involves using a robotic device and the
robotic device has a series of games
that robot sort of fits over top of a
person's arm and there's a series of
games that a person plays that
challenges them to move their arm if
they cannot move their arm at all then
the robot will help them a hundred
percent as they learn the robot will
decrease the amount of help as the
person increases their effort so the
goal is to really remove the robotic
device in the end and then have the
person just using your arm so that's
that's the idea this one has a little
bit of a caveat in that we also apply a
pharmacological agent that we believe is
useful for improving learning so what a
person has a stroke they are essentially
relearning old skills so where you we're
testing a research question that the
robotic therapy Plus this
pharmacological pharmacological agent is
better than the robot therapy plus a
sham treatment or a placebo treatment
which is a just a sugar pill so I don't
know who gets the drug the subjects
don't know who gets the drug and none of
the evaluators get the drug in the end
when the studies done then we break the
blinding and then we figure out who did
better based upon what study arm they
were in we know that the robotic
training works but again like in many
many investigational studies you sort of
add one therapy plus another therapy to
think that you'll get even better so
that's really our research question can
we add robot plus the pharmacological
therapy to get an even better so and
this has happened the robot has improved
people who were
you know one would think is that may not
improve if you're in your 70s 80s and
90s you may not think you can prove but
we have data that suggests that you can
the reason it is not just the robot the
robot will help but it's the games and I
mentioned that term neuroplasticity the
changing in the brain now are there are
certain certain items that need to occur
for the brain to change one of those is
being attentive so you have to attend to
something also you have to be motivated
to do it if you're not motivated to do
something you rarely learn just think of
a a tennis game if you're really not
interested in playing tennis and your
your father sends you out to play tennis
and you just aren't very interested
you're not going to learn the skill very
well it's the same thing with these
games what the robot does is that it has
a computer program that's along with it
think of it like a video game and the
video game has a series of levels all
the way from zero which is the easiest
to 10 which is the most difficult the
games like you said are motivational
that make you attend they're challenging
and they're progressively increase the
difficulty level all of those things are
important for brain plasticity
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University